notre laboratoire ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on essaie de comprendre la
connectivité du cerveau on veut
cartographier la matière blanche
l'utilité de softs et comprendre les
troubles neurologiques
[Musique]
ces troubles aux salles a fait des
centaines de milliers de canadiens
chaque année puis salle eu des
conséquences pour les individus mais
aussi ça coûte des dizaines de milliards
de dollars au gouvernement
nous on fait ça pour aider la recherche
qui est des d'enfants à améliorer les
traitements contre les personnes ou à
découvrir ces trous bleus à vingt que
les personnes développent des symptômes